let's go next to Grant from Iowa City
Grant welcome to the program what's on
your mind
hey David uh great great to talk with
you again likewise
um
so
I'd like to have a variety of different
perspectives I hear from in many areas
of life just to like further
uh develop my
own ideas about how I truly feel about
things and I also think it's good to
learn
um people feel about
a given topic so that I can empathize
with them better and connect with them
better but yeah I usually don't have an
issue doing this except when it comes to
politics I have a hard time finding
anyone who's really interesting or
valuable to listen to on the right I was
just wondering if you had
anyone you could think of that would be
like someone like I guess worth
listening to um because I find usually
they're either
uh ignorant or morally arrogant or even
just rude perhaps
um and I just it's kind of a waste of
time but I I would like to actually you
know engage with some ideas that I
disagree with yeah I don't have anybody
specific I mean well so is there a
particular issue on which you would like
such a person
but not really I guess I think just in
general General right winger
I don't know I wish I had someone to
recommend but I really don't at this
point in time yeah I wasn't sure if you
would I know you're busy doing your own
thing but yeah
it's just because and I have a fair
number of you know close relatives and
friends for conservative but yeah they
don't get too involved politically and
so it's kind of like well I don't really
think through the issues too much it's
kind of just you know their gut reaction
to Things based on
whatever their upbringing or their yeah
theological views or whatever but do you
like engaging with those people or is it
more of an annoyance
I enjoy it um it's just I feel like we
don't really get down to the
nitty-gritty of stuff because
it's um pretty surface level and in the
minute you know I start trying to talk
about something more deeper level they
either get kind of lost in it or they
just lose interest or yeah whatever
um because yeah I mean as far as actual
political commentators I've like tried
listening to like Ben Shapiro and it's
like it's pretty painful name on the
right but I just like can't really do it
yeah no I don't blame you I don't you
know what I would suggest is rather than
just like finding that stuff find some
like find some books that maybe would
give you a more sensible
um panorama on some of these right-wing
ideologies from like more traditional
conservatives I still don't really know
exactly who I'd recommend but I would go
that direction rather than trying to
figure out you know by listening to Ben
Shapiro
okay yeah right
um all right my friend thank you for the
call
okay
thanks all right very good uh there is
Grant very very strong let's go next to
uh let's go to Elias from Pennsylvania
Elias welcome to the program what's on
your mind today
hey David I haven't called in a while
how are you I'm doing well thank you
um I have been listening to a whole
bunch of leftist streamers recently okay
uh and the idea I've been getting is
that we need a more cohesive online left
um to take advantage of you know the Gen
Z voter base that showed itself most
recently sure and we don't really have a
cohesive message and I was wondering if
you had any ideas for Gathering the
online left to have a more you know
online a stronger online community
uh you know the reason that this is
really tough is that by definition the
left is a little more fractured in that
we I I feel are more resistant to just
wanting to be part of like one big tent
to some degree because
we often allow the perfect to become the
enemy of the good and what I don't like
sometimes seeing on the left is people
who were aligned on 90 of issues
saying I can't be with this person or
that person in the same Coalition
because of the five or ten percent on
which we differ and I think that that
fundamentally gets in the way of
building the bigger consensus like
you're talking about I would love to see
that to a great degree I don't know who
would organize it and I think that
there's something about the left that is
more antithetical to welcoming and
accepting that so I I'd have to devote
some more thought to it I love the idea
I think the left needs to be better
organized I just don't know exactly what
the Hub or the Crux of it would be
hello
hello
I guess he's gone okay that was that was
weird